-Welcome back.
I'm here with Ana de Armas.
She stars as Marilyn Monroe in
the Netflix movie "Blonde,"
and we're about to test
our film knowledge
in a new game we call
"Three-Word Movie."
Here we go.
-♪ Three-word movie ♪
-Alright. Here's how it works.
We're going to pick a card with
a name of a movie title on it
and we have to get the other
person to guess the title
using only three words as clues.
The clues cannot be the name of
anyone in the movie
or the director or any word
in the title.
-Okay.
-Ready for this?
-Mm-hmm.
-Yeah.
What happ-- We played a game
last time you were here, yeah?
-Yeah. You won.
Very, very upset about that.
-I didn't even remember.
No big deal.
We'll be right back.
No, I'm just kidding.
Here we go.
Well, actually,
why don't you go first?
You're my guest.
-You want me to go first?
-Yeah. You go.
You pick the card.
And then you -- I won't see it.
But give me three clues
and I'll see if I can guess it.
-Hmm.
This one is very tempting
because --
[ Laughter ]
But that would be a bad word.
So...
[ Laughter ]
-You want to say it, you can say
it if you want to.
-Let's just say "cat."
-Okay.
-What would be
a bad word for "cat"?
-Okay.
-I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Shoes.
-Uh-huh.
-Ogre.
-Ogre, cat, shoes?
Well, but -- Yeah, but --
[ Laughter ]
"Puss in Boots."
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I got it? I got it.
It took me a while.
I'm slow, but I get it.
Okay. Here we go.
Alright, here we go.
-You got it. Okay.
-Well done.
-Oh, gosh.
-Okay.
-This is horrible.
[ Laughter ]
Ugh!
-Speed!
[ Laughter ]
Flying!
-Um, don't say it again.
-Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-It has to be "Top Gun."
-Yes, exactly.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
Why did you say "speed" so much?
-'Cause I wanted to really
channel my Tom Cruise.
I was, like, trying to give
that energy that he does.
He's unbelievable.
Alright. Your turn now.
But here's the deal.
-Oh.
-Round two, this round is
a little harder
because now we can only use two
clues, so the game has changed.
It's now "Two-Word Movie."
This has never happened before.
We're playing a brand-new game.
This is "Two-Word Movie."
-You didn't think of
the name before.
-No. We keep changing the --
Yeah. So, this is it.
We're playing the game
"Two-Word Movie."
-Oh, I love this movie.
Okay.
Travel.
Ah.
DeLorean.
[ Audience ahhs ]
That was too easy.
-No. I like that!
"Back to the Future"!
-Yes!
[ Ding! ]
That was too easy.
-That's not too easy.
It's fine.
I like that.
-I really don't know
who's winning.
-Yeah, I'm not sure
who wins this game.
-Okay.
-Two words?
[ Laughter ]
I don't need two words.
-Oh. I do.
[ Laughter ]
-Ready?
[ as Elvis ] Music.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, you don't.
-[ Normal voice ]
One word, right? Here we go.
Just say it.
-"Elvis."
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-I love that too.
-Yeah.
-Alright. Final round.
This round we can only
use one word.
It's a game we call
"One-Word Movie."
-So for this one, you have zero
because you do one word now.
-Yes. Exactly, yeah. Okay.
-Oh, I love this movie.
I love my movies.
[ Audience oohs ]
-One word.
-If you don't understand
because of my accent,
you missed your chance.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
One word with an accent.
-Redrum.
[ Audience ohhs ]
-"The Shining"?
-Yes!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm not even going to go.
I'm not even going to go.
Ana de Armas!
That's incredible.
That's how you do it. Redrum.
-Yes.
-Redrum.
Thank you to Ana de Armas.
"Blonde" is available now
on Netflix.
We'll be right back with
Luke Grimes.
Redrum, right?